[Music]
elementary aged astronauts fight with
wild tigers and stop motion horror
decades in the making from slasher
flicks to period piece thrillers these
are the sleeper hit movies of 2022
as the horrors of school shootings have
become a terrifying and tragic part of
everyday reality for american youths it
can be difficult to imagine how to begin
to tackle this topic in the context of a
movie in contrast to the tone death stab
at relevant showrunners made in the
shooting star episode of glee the
fallout tackles the psychology of a
teenager living in the wake of a school
shooting with depth and specificity the
teenager in question veda cavall
experiences trauma extending far beyond
just the school shooting event itself
just trying to go back to high school
becomes an enormous trial and her
outlets for controlling her anxiety
aren't always as healthy as they could
be the remarkable thing about writer
director megan parks work on the fallout
is the sheer variety she lends to each
of the high schoolers depicted in this
story there's never one way to cope with
trauma and the same can be said for
surviving a school shooting vader and
her friends register as real human
beings thanks to the fallout taking the
time to outline the specific and varied
ways they're each moving forward in
their lives after unspeakable horrors
there isn't
there's no reason
none of us should have died
meanwhile the lead performance from
jenna ortega is remarkable especially
her subtle detailed depiction of vader
shutting out those around her the
fallout is far from an easy watch but
it's an unflinching and emotionally
astute piece of filmmaking
the people we lionize in society are
just people like everyone else it can be
easy to forget that in everyday life but
askgar for hardy's a hero which played
at cannes in 2021 but hit prime video in
2022 is a perfect reminder of this truth
the film tells the story of rahim played
by amir jadidi who was recently released
from prison as he begins to rebuild his
life he returns a bag of money to its
rightful owner making him a hero in the
eyes of his neighbors and community
however raheem's past comes back to
haunt him as dissenting voices begin to
question the validity of his actions not
only does this place his new reputation
in danger but it also begins to eat away
at raheem's ability to secure new
employment and stake out a post-prison
existence the same nuance and richly
detailed characterizations that farhadi
brought to his 2011 masterpiece as
separation are once again present in a
hero these intricacies make the ensuing
tragedy of the plotline all the more
compelling to watch as does the
delicately thoughtful camera work from
for hottie and cinematographer ali ghazi
the cinematography is especially
unforgettable in the film's closing shot
which leaves viewers with a sense of
unshakable despair boasting a 96 score
on rotten tomatoes and bizarrely
overlooked for a best international
feature oscar nomination a hero is
another asgard for hottie gym that is
well worth watching
from ai artificial intelligence to
bicentennial man there have been plenty
of movies navigating the relationship
between human families and robotic
companions however none of them have
been quite like after yank the latest
film from director koganata the film
chronicles a family led by their father
jake played by colin farrell figuring
out what to do once their longtime robot
yang abruptly shuts down while
determining the next steps for this
mechanical being that was so important
to his family jake begins to uncover
extraordinary things in yang's memories
this discovery suggests he was even more
complex and human than they could have
imagined the contemplative style of
filmmaking koganata applied to his 2017
film columbus is alive and well in its
follow-up but after yang is far from a
reprise of the director's previous
cinematic effort the ingenious use of
shifting aspect ratios paired with
kogonada's striking editing techniques
gives after yang a distinct visual
identity meanwhile the quiet pieces of
unique technology and architecture
surrounding the characters suggest a
broader near future world without
overwhelming the story the filmmaking
and melancholy ambiance are so
captivating that they make this movie
feel like the very first film to ever
tackle the idea of distinctly human
traits lurking inside a robotic being
the tale of cyrano de bergerac has been
captivating audiences in various mediums
for well over a century however no one
has told this adventurous story in quite
the way joe wright does in cyrano
pleasure to meet you sereno de bergerac
this 2022 film brings the story to life
as a musical headline by peter dinklage
in the titular role the story of an
expert swordsman who believes himself to
be too hideous to be loved by the woman
of his dreams it's a tragic romantic
yarn that burst off the screen with
palpable pathos this is a movie that
wears its sentimental belief in
old-fashioned love on its sleeve and
it's all the better for such a
cynicism-free execution this
straightforward approach to the romance
is mirrored by the confident execution
of the music from random conversations
punctuated by melody to letters read
aloud through lead actor haley bennett's
sensual crooning the songs spring from
the lips of cast members at any given
opportunity cyrano has no qualms about
beating its own drum which comes in
especially handy during its emotionally
devastating musical sequences some may
find it more hokey than moving but if
you like old-fashioned romantic dramas
that throw subtly and caution to the
wind then cyrano will deeply move you
in the grand tradition of rope or buried
the outfit largely takes place in one
location in this case that singular
backdrop is the clothing store of cutter
leonard burling played by mark rylance
he prides himself on making the finest
clothes possible for his customers as
well as how he stays out of the way of
the mobsters who use his place to hold
money in letters one late night this
shop becomes a hotbed of activity when
gangster richie boyle is killed by a
fellow mobster thus begins a night of
increasingly dangerous activity that
sees this mild-mannered expert in
fashion using all his wits to stay alive
writer and director graham moore does
fine work utilizing this simple premise
and minimalist environments to create an
engaging crime thriller part of the
film's charm comes from moore's
willingness to have dark fun with his
material the r rating provided the
filmmaker freedom to include realistic
bursts of bloody mayhem and impactful
dialogue laden with coarse language mark
rylance's years of stage experience
serves him well within the confined set
and he manages to keep viewers engaged
with minimal resources unsurprisingly
the oscar winner proved the perfect lead
for the tense thriller some movies only
offer excess spectacle but no heart
other is merely schmaltz but no scope
rrr an epic blockbuster hailing from
director ss roger mooley wisely decides
to deliver both of these ingredients at
once this story concerns two men komaram
beam and the lori sidorama raju in
1920's delhi the duo sparks up a deeply
passionate friendship without realizing
the other's true identity beam is on a
mission to rescue a young girl who was
kidnapped from his village while raju is
a cop who demonstrates deep loyalty to
brutally cruel colonial figures like
governor scott buxton rrr delivers one
riotously over-the-top action scene
after another any pretense towards being
grounded has been tossed to the wind in
favor of delightfully maximalist chaos
at the same time there's a genuineness
to how rajamouli depicts the friendship
between beam and raju that makes it
impossible not to get wrapped up in
their bond depictions of this duo
standing strong and fighting back
against cruel colonial forces also stir
the soul there's a beating heart to rrr
that lends deep humanity to a movie that
also features exploding trains and
flaming carriages tossing in a bevy of
remarkably catchy tunes like nattunatu
and rrr becomes a cinematic delight one
can't miss
writer and director richard link later
returns to the world of rotoscope
filmmaking with apollo 10 and a half a
space age childhood for this production
link later splits the story between the
real and the fantastical part of the
runtime is concerned with chronicling
the exploits of young stanley growing up
in 1960s houston texas when the space
race was everywhere the film is somewhat
autobiographical for link later and
authenticity reverberates off these
recollections of the highs and lows of
such an important historical period
however apollo 10 and a half also
ventures into a heightened yarn about
stanley being called in by nasa for a
top-secret mission where he gets sent to
the moon before neil armstrong and buzz
aldrin the combination of the disparate
narratives and apollo 10 and a half is
fairly seamless and it's greatly
assisted by jack black's wall to wall
narration which bridges the gap between
stanley's home life and his voyage to
the stars
okay pause
let's forget about all this for now
we'll come back to this part later
even better link later injects amusingly
specific details into stanley's
reminiscing about childhood elements
like his uber-paranoid grandmother or
how his mom could make one ham dinner
last an entire week the entire story is
told through nicely realized hand-drawn
animated rotoscoping a welcome return of
an art form link later used so well on
earlier projects like a scanner darkly
with these qualities it becomes quite
easy to recommend apollo 10 and a half
as a trip worth taking
when director punapanahi's hit the road
begins it appears that the film will
focus on a married couple and their two
sons on a road trip across iraq
slowly but surely though panahi peels
back the layers on this family and their
excursions to reveal deeper darker
truths this is anything but a normal
road trip and it quickly becomes
apparent that we're watching an exercise
in quiet tragedy masquerading as
familial normalcy the film's power is
especially apparent in how each of the
lead characters gets a unique and
distinctive point of view the
intentionally cramped confines of the
narrative allow us time to get to know
everyone in this family while the
restrained camera work offers subtle
glimpses into their interior worlds
panahi's strengths as a filmmaker are
further reinforced by how well he can
incorporate bursts of dark humor into
hit the road without undercutting its
ominous tone above all else pantea
panaya's performance as the unnamed
mother of this family may be the
ultimate reason to see the film
especially her work in the film's
devastating final sequence performances
like that just like movies as good as
hit the road are far from commonplace
824's horror fair has often gone in
artsy directions with an emphasis on
long stretches of silence meditative
wide shots and abstract imagery x a
title from the studio thrust into
theaters in march 2022 goes down a
different lane with its horror
influences being more in the vein of the
texas chainsaw massacre with a 1970s
porno shoot as the backdrop x is a
different beast compared to hereditary
or the witch but no less well crafted
like many of its predecessors this a24
horror film is a compelling watch as for
the plot the film follows a group of
young filmmakers as they show up at a
texas ranch to make an adult movie
needless to say things do not go
according to plan writer and director ty
west isn't reinventing the mold here but
he doesn't need to this is a film that
conveys a giddy glee in playing with the
grisly storytelling hallmarks of the
slasher movie genre and getting
audiences all round up with anticipation
by overtly teeing up gruesome ways for
characters to perish in between all that
fun there's even an occasionally
poignant undercurrent to x about
mortality and who modern society deems
attractive these themes add some heft to
the proceedings but if you just want to
watch x for the gore and titillation
there's plenty of that to satisfy x is a
departure from the standards of many
other scary a24 titles but following its
own creative path serves it mighty well
gerard carmichael not only stars in the
on the count of three he also makes his
directorial debut with this extremely
heavy film centered around suicide
specifically the film is about lifelong
best friends val played by carmichael
and kevin played by christopher abbott
committing to a pact that they'll kill
themselves by the end of the day it's a
brutal and heavy premise told with
deftly executed dark humor
i don't listen to atlantis more set when
i'm going through a breakup and i'm not
listening to papa roach on the day i'm
going to kill myself much of this comes
from how screenwriters ari catcher and
ryan welch pull no punches in trying to
make the audience understand these
characters and their complex motives
we're always in tune with the deep
psychological trauma that's making them
believe that suicide is a reasonable
option to escape their tormented
existences the empathetic nature of on
the count of three is especially
apparent in the mesmerizing performance
by christopher abbott as kevin a man
just barely keeping his long simmering
pain under the surface abbott can break
your heart with a facial expression and
both he and carmichael have authentic
lived in chemistry with one another on
the count of three is not an easy watch
far from it but those who are able to
take it in will be gifted with an
impressive first foray into filmmaking
from carmichael as well as one of the
year's best performances from abbott
in her second feature-length directorial
effort director audrey dewan delivers an
extraordinary piece of cinema in the
form of happening this production tells
the story of anne played by anna maria
vartolime a young woman living in france
in 1963. her hefty ambitions for the
future get upended when she learns she's
pregnant all anne wants to do is get an
abortion and move on with her future but
abortions are outlawed in france in this
era now anne has to sneak around
speaking in secrecy and using subtle
glances to reveal her true feelings
while keeping her crisis from everyone
around her it's an intense storyline
that dejuan brings to life with subtle
but impactful power among the film's
many strengths is rartola may's
performance in the lead role handed
apart largely eschewing overt dialogue
vartalimay works wonders in conveying
ann's thought process via quieter means
duwan's direction is also remarkable
with visual details like a constricted
aspect ratio illustrating how confined
and feels in her day-to-day life all of
these thoughtful touches add up to a
movie you can't shake off once it's over
happening isn't just a sign of dejuan's
powers as a director it's also an
exceptional ode to what human beings
endure in the face of inhumane laws
in production for decades mad god is a
labor of love from phil tippett an icon
of the stop-motion animation industry
it's a miracle this film ever managed to
see the light of day considering that it
took crowdsourcing to get the funds
necessary to bring this warped vision to
life all of that time effort and money
were spent on a feature that largely
eschews plot in favor of delivering
increasingly disturbing visions of a
post-apocalyptic world where suffering
is omnipresent doctors deprive people of
their guts rather than save anyone while
husks of human beings are created often
solely to die in the abyss
mad god isn't just dark it's
relentlessly bleak while such a tone
won't be for everyone those that can get
on tipit's wavelength will be happy with
what mad god delivers running just a
hair under 80 minutes before the credits
begin mad god manages to constantly
deliver unpredictable and unnerving
imagery brimming with imagination the
various textures provided by the
stop-motion medium make the film appear
more viscerally appalling and unique
it's hard to comprehend an entirely
computer-generated nightmare world like
this one being nearly as impactful just
as it's difficult to imagine many other
2022 titles being as lastingly chilling
as mad god
if you're going to watch anyone talk in
a hotel room for 90 minutes it might as
well be an instantly compelling
performer like emma thompson she takes
on the role of nancy stokes and good
luck to you leo grant while daryl
mccormack plays the titular part of a
male sex worker after her husband passes
away nancy decides to finally engage in
the sexual exploits that have been a
mystery to her for decades hiring leo
for an hour or two of passion
number three we do a 69 if that's what
it's still called
i don't know um four me on top five
doggy style what sounds like a simple
arrangement becomes anything but as
stokes begins to open up more and more
to grant katie brand's screenplay
ensures that the dialogue between these
two characters is as humorous as it is
revealing the boldly intimate scope of
the project which is largely confined to
one hotel room proves to be a boon to
good luck to you leo grant offering
viewers a chance to understand the finer
nuances of this duo without any
distractions what's more the film allows
moviegoers the opportunity to appreciate
the exceptional lead performances by
thompson and mccormack good luck to you
leo grand is the newest reminder that
you don't need an enormous story to make
an engrossing movie
one of the first scenes in neptune frost
depicts people chanting and banging on
drums in the grim domain of a mine where
a worker has just perished these
performers are an aberration in this
environment but that's the point within
this sequence neptune frost has
established that music can appear
anywhere the same is true for things
like the spirit of rebellion empathy
towards other human beings and one's
true identity no matter how much
oppressive societies try to stifle or
even wipe out these forces they will
endure hinging on this concept neptune
frost reveals itself to be a stirring
battle cry in cinematic form directors
saul williams and anisha uziman tell the
tale of neptune played by both elvis and
gabo and sharail ishaja who joins a
hacking initiative there's a visual
audacity particularly when it comes to
costume and production design in fact
this might be the only film to feature a
major character in an outfit made
completely out of keyboard keys such
elements reflect how this film focuses
on a collection of human beings who can
finally be themselves away from
oppressive systemic forces insightful
dialogue by the film's protagonist
reinforces the movie's touching
exploration of individuals finally
discovering the space to embrace their
own identity there's a beating
captivating heart to neptune frost which
informs its ceaseless creativity and
unwavering rebellion against fascism
even the most jaded viewers won't be
able to resist something this stirring
the way racism is ingrained into the
fabric of america and its institutions
is such an overwhelming part of reality
that even beginning to approach it in
film can intimidate filmmakers the
documentary who we are a chronicle of
racism in america hailing from directors
emily and sarah kunsler provides an
expansive look at the past and present
of racism's impact on the u.s the story
is told through the words of aclu deputy
legal director jeffrey robinson the film
split between clips of him giving a talk
about the history of america's racism to
a packed crowd and segments depicting
robinson talking to various american
citizens about this urgently relevant
topic
who we are is a heavy watch as it should
be the filmmakers and robinson refused
to distill the horrors of bigotry to
just flat readings of statistics there's
a passionate fervor in robinson's public
speaking skills as he dives into the
nuances of how racism has informed key
parts of america's foundation
who controls the past controls the
future and your children they are being
taught that slavery was a side issue in
the civil war
meanwhile his interviews remind viewers
of the human cost of systemic racism
being normalized the overwhelming
reality of intolerance in america is
superbly reflected within the lens of
who we are
[Music]